our next guest once held every just
about every choice school record until
Trevor Lawrence came along but he went
on to set numerous passing records at
Clemson but Trevor Lawrence is probably
gonna break those two nevertheless he
was a first-round pick of the Texans
he's considered one of the great young
quarterbacks in the NFL
that is until Trevor Lawrence gets
drafted by an NFL team please welcome
DeSean watch
[Music]
Gatorade is created a limited-edition
flavor especially specifically for the
Super Bowl and you can go to Gatorade
dot-com promo code Gatorade SB for 20%
off your purchase good to have you back
thank you appreciate you think you were
just gonna get compliments walking we
had to roast you just a little bit it's
all good I can take it
last year you wore jeans and they had
rips in them right and I said let me see
your scar and you showed me the scar and
I think this is what people don't see
you know they know somebody gets injured
the rehab the long you know process
there but what was what was that next
morning like after you had knee surgery
a lot of sleeping a lot of pain
it's just a lot of just I don't know
much any a lot of doubt yeah just you
know trying to imagine the time that I'm
gonna be out you know when can I walk
again I couldn't feel my leg so uh just
everything was just kind of going
through my mind and then you get out
there for the first time and then you
you know you you're gonna move a little
bit like how what is that like when
you're out there and you got scar tissue
but but you got to get out there and you
got to test it now I was scary
honestly is it's a lot of uh you gotta
have a lot of trust in the preparation
that she did previously and you gotta
have uh you know just to trust that you
know it's gonna be everything
everything's gonna be alright did you
want to get hit no not at all okay
because some players talk about let me
just get hit and then I'm gonna move
past this or I'm now I'm back as a
football pull out me for me it was more
kind of just cutting on it getting hit
I'm fine I don't want to get hit but as
far as running just running straight for
speeding be able to cut that's what I
was worried about have you been hit
where you still feel it
not really nobody actually yes yes yes
the Cowboys game who got you Jalen I
think is just before the end he wanted
to the end zone
here's arms as big as your thighs I mean
he's a big yes so he tracked you down
he tracked me down and got me he got me
good sure and then is there anything
shed nah he's just gotta hop hopped up
and don't say anything I can't say
anything have you said anything to any
defensive players so far in your career
a little bit of smack talk do with who
but it was more it was more fun I guess
it wasn't really asked Matt talk so I
guess not really I mean the Eagles game
were I was talking with the D llama
now what do you say oh they're like
you're we're gonna be in your grill all
day listen I'm right here okay that's
not really trying no I don't really
trash talk to people people don't really
trash talk to me either
but you're not a trash talk guy yeah you
just play I just play ball
oh by the way congrats you bought your
mom a house I did now explain that to
the audience how that came about how did
you surprise mom well I'm kind of
partnered with house so it really was a
home that we already had it was just we
kind of remodeled the whole deal the
inside my mom had to have it at home and
you know I just partner with house and
we did I just show that kind of
remodeled so I got some people to come
in and help me out with that and kind of
took out the whole kitchen living room
always everything he kind of made it I
guess up to date and you know she came
in she put her in an Airbnb for a couple
months and came back home and she came
and saw it's pretty dope she cry she did
did you know I didn't cry but I was very
very excited how about this you redo
homes for athletes moms and you're the
host yes sir
we think that's awesome I love that I'm
in it with you I mean I'm the creator
[Laughter]
HGTV and you just you just redo homes
for uh the parents for our athletes
family I'm down with that
although the athletes should be buying
their parents a home but you know they
can but you come in and you're able to
like you partner with Jay Jay want right
and then you guys just go in and you
have a reveal I'm down with that
all right now how good a basketball
player were you I was pretty good
let's get another plane in college you
could have played a Clemson could have
played at Clemson could you have started
Eclipse for sure really this year every
time I went up the Clemson we did like
basketball can't beat Clemson and the
coach was is very he's a big fan he
wanted me to play both but Clemson
wasn't that good of a bass he's like
yeah I know but I'm just saying I mean
they really weren't that it's not like
it was Duke
oh they recruit you know basketball no
okay now I read this I don't know if
it's true that you idolize JJ reddick I
did and that's they do really yeah
because oh okay me and my mom we grew up
do fans my mom Coach K she loved Duke so
that's what I was raised on and at that
time when I was watching basketball and
playing
ijj I read it was a guy he had number
four which was my favorite number he can
shoot threes which what I like to do and
I just felt like you met JJ reddick I
have not have not we exchanged hits and
uh you know jerseys and they like that
but I haven't met him yet
Paulie bring out JJ Redick if you could
have played if you could have played two
sports at Duke would you have gone to
Duke for sure really I think yeah if
Coach K would have recruited me to play
basketball I think I would have probably
gave it a real chance for sure but you
had to play for Duke football though
then I would have went to the NBA do you
understand what Kyler Murray what that
decision must be like other stuff I mean
growing up in baseball and then getting
drafted you know in the first round and
that and then you have an opportunity I
don't know it it would be tough for me
you know kind of trying to choose which
one I want to do especially if I love
both of them
you you got a degree in communications
yes sir what are you gonna do with it
I might take your show
well bring it on I'm here all day but if
I can help you I'd be more than happy to
see ya do you want it do you want
actually want to be in this in the media
I think so honestly I would like to have
it that was my dream that's the reason
why I took communication to be able to
learn about media and just talking
especially its audience and okay I'm
gonna give you 30 seconds no you got 30
seconds to analyze what the Rams have to
do to beat the Patriots so the Rams the
Los Angeles Rams have three things they
have to no turnovers on offense and the
Reds don't score touchdowns play with a
lot of confidence and the defense just
have to play their P's and Q's and and
do whatever they did in the game plan
and and don't bust any plays they'll be
just fun okay what are the Patriots
debate rights just be the page that's a
good answer I like that one when you see
Brady
what does Brady do better than you I
feel like the knowledge of the the game
and their spirits and know what the
defense is doing before they even do it
and know where to go with the ball
before the ball is even even snot so he
gets the line of scrimmage you think he
knows where everybody's gonna be for
sure he has a great idea not 100% but I
think for sure he know exactly where
he's going with the ball from the film
I've seen and watched with OB and the
things that he told me about Tom and and
just I mean what 17 18 years that he's
seen things I think he pretty much know
where he's going so B's O'Brien coach Oh
bro bro okay have you talked to Brady I
had before yeah but not not throughout
the season but is it just after a game
we talked you know after a game but we
testing the off season last year when I
first met him
oh you did yeah and what do you ask him
no I mean we just he sent me his book
and we kind of just briefed kind of just
touch base on are you on the tv12 diet
no I don't know if it can make you Tom
Brady would you eat that
would you have that no Tom Brady
probably not you still wouldn't I
probably wouldn't have my own diet I
want to be my own you know
show us you know TV for now DW for okay
all right
what's your nickname nickname I guess dy
DW for Dufour wait you don't have a
nickname now I can nickname at least I
don't think so
well you got to come up with a nickname
me or somebody yes somebody fans can do
it yeah so DW for cuz then it sounds
like Dee Ford rightfully and you don't
want to be D for to the Chiefs no we'll
come up with something yes McLovin I got
one
okay how about elementary my dear Watson
what Sherlock Holmes after he solved the
crime would say elementary my dear
Watson
you know you score a touchdown and be
like oh that was elementary my dear
Watson because then it's elementary and
he's not Elementary oh yeah that would
have been better anyway it's a master's
degree not elemental yeah now we're
gonna have to get DW for deshaun joining
us on behalf of Gatorade and
limited-edition flavors specifically for
the Super Bowl hear this and he brought
some for for all of us Gatorade dot-com
promo code Gatorade SB for 20 percent
off your purchase it's great to see you
again
I'm glad you're healthy and we hope to
see you again thanks for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]